hi I'm Erik Bosse and spider-man into
the spider-verse is such an impressive
work of animation it's ringing up there
among the best spider-man stories
because it actually gets what it's like
to read a spider-man comic book and
translate all that so beautifully to
scream like nothing against emo Peter
tall Peter or Peter third time's a charm
but there's so much more to spider-man
comics and a story that celebrates the
full spider-man history with some
amazing visual storytelling really just
nailed what we love about the character
so I'm gonna break down this movie scene
by scene to point out all the cool
details that you might have overlooked
hidden animation jokes and Easter eggs
but also subtle creative choices made by
the filmmakers to make into the
spider-verse work so well spoiler
warning if you haven't see the movie yet
and let's get started okay the opening
frames of this movie already set it
apart from every other spider-man movie
that we've seen in really every animated
movie that we've seen before this studio
logos are depicted with these bhende
dots which appear actually throughout
every frame of the movie filmmakers have
into the spider-verse head a difficult
task before them because the spider-man
character had already been rebooted so
many times on film and they wanted this
one to feel distinct their concept was
for it to feel like a living painting as
if you were walking into an actual comic
book so you see all these comic book
aesthetics throughout the movie the
bidet dots along with hatching lines and
both of these are used by older comic
books to shade images without having to
spend so much ink and of course you see
split screen panels and action words
thought panels and talking bubbles but
beyond these visuals the filmmakers also
had to rebuild a whole new style of
animation that you only really perceive
on a subconscious level so standard film
is shot on 24 frames per second and
modern animated films follow this model
with a movement of like a Pixar movie
blending pretty smoothly because every
second is made up of 24 individuals
still images but four into the
spider-verse the animators had to
animate in twos that means doubling each
frame so that you essentially get 12
frames per second that was how
traditional old-school animation was
done so they reconstructed that style to
give this movie a certain crispness to
the movement from character's hair or
clothing making things look almost in
their words crunchy and sharp so that
you really have impact with an image it
burns into your psyche that is why when
you watch this movie the art of each
frame really stands out can
like when you read a comic book each
moment is so punctuated by the way Sony
is actually trying to patent this
animation technology this whole comic
book motif is also the reason for this
stamp in the opening frames approved by
the comic books code Authority the comic
books code Authority was a set of
guidelines for comic books about fifties
to assure parents that comic books
wouldn't turn their kids into sexual
deviants or criminals or communists yeah
nice try fascists these guidelines
forbid creating sympathy for the
criminal same crime shouldn't be
glamorous but rather a sordid and
unpleasant activity and that criminal
should be shown being punished for their
actions
you know this step isn't just a joke end
of the spider-verse actually abides by
these rules villains like kingpin and
Aaron Davis might be showing some
sympathy in that I guess their behavior
is motivated by something deeper than
simple pure evil but you know their
criminality doesn't really look fun they
suffer a lot no kids gonna want to
emulate them or dress up for them as
Halloween or if you're me any time of
the year if he opening titles we also
see there were a Korean number of 42
shows upon a spider and on the lottery
ball for miles being selected for his
school later it appears as cluttered
numbers from a shattered street address
sign 42 is actually the number of the
radioactive spider that bites miles in
the ultimate spider-man comics it was
the 42nd test of the spider that
actually worked in this movie the number
42 appears over and over kind of to
haunt miles whenever his new spider-man
powers burden him kind of like a curse
and through all this we hear the voice
of spider-man the Peter Parker of this
Ultimate Universe he's voiced by Chris
Pine and he says alright let's do this
one last time which is repeated over and
over again by every new spider-man that
we meet it's of course a nod to the
endless numbers of reboots and
reintroduction to Spidey in movies over
the years a spider-man comic book funk
Stan a print of us on the table on the
cover you can see the signature if
someone named in the big nollie Marcello
thick nylon time film animator an artist
who worked on this movie but every time
we see a new spider-man introduced the
comic book cover changes to credit the
comic book artist who created those
characters so like at the end of the
film when we get introduced to Miles
officially comic book artist Brian
Michael Bendis and Sarah Pacelli are on
the cover and when we meet spider twin
it's Jason Latour and Robbie Rodriguez
for spider-man noir it's David Hein
Fabrice Paul ski and karma
Giada minseo and for penny Parker its
Gerard Way and Jake Wyatt now as I said
this first spider-man universe is the
one from The Ultimate Comics this is
Earth 1610 it's an alternate dimension
from our normal default universe
earth-616 that's why a lot of the
products I have alternate reality spins
on them like there's red X instead of
FedEx PD and why instead of NYPD coca
soda instead of RC Cola
yep that's a sound of a hundred
commentators who don't get the jokes
correct any sane coke obviously in the
Ultimate Comics Peter Parker actually
dies and Miles Morales takes over in
this Peter also has blonde hair which
could be a nod to the Ben Riley
spider-man from the Clone Saga Peter's
introduction references several moments
from the Sam Raimi spider-man trilogy
with Tobey Maguire there was the train
rescue for spider-man to the upside down
MJ kiss from the first one the car
flying through the window in spider-man
2 and of course the cringy pointing and
dancing for spider-man 3 the cover of
the amazing spider-man 186 shows up but
here the title has actually been changed
to true like tales there's also a girl
eating Spidey O's cereal
perhaps a nod to the real spider-man
cereal from the 90s that was promoted
with these Spiderman animated series we
also see a spider-man popsicle it's also
a real thing and a brief shot from the
60s Spiderman animated series that gets
a big shout out in the post-credits
scene and then this apartment Christmas
album includes titles like Spidey it's
cold outside swinging around the
mistletoe silent night you're welcome
joy to the world that I just saved
Spidey the snowman it's beginning to
look a lot like a nondenominational
holiday and Ave Maria no joke on that
one
that's no pun next we meet the hero of
this movie Miles Morales always spice
shameik Moore he's singing the song
sunflower it's a song written
specifically for this movie but I pushed
him alone he actually makes a cameo
later in this movie as a Brooklyn
bystander
now Myles is background it's quite
different from Peter Parker's Myles
lives in Brooklyn not Queens and he
still has his parents he's the son of a
black father and a Puerto Rican mother
now his father Jefferson Davis is voiced
by Brian Tyree Henry he's a cop with a
PD NY and look closely at his police
cruiser and has a license plate reading
RFD 960 it's actually the same tag
number for the car that a detectives
drive in a show Law & Order and miles
dad mist quotes the famous Uncle Ben
quote saying with great ability comes
great accountability quote actually
comes up a couple times throughout the
movie
miles attends the Brooklyn visions
Academy and in his English class he's
assigned Charles Dickens great
expectations which actually sets up
another running theme in the movie like
the character pip and great expectations
Myles struggles to live up to the
expectations of this new elite society
that he wants to join when Stacy is kind
of this movie's parallel to Estella who
is pips romantic aspiration but as we
will see throughout this movie Myles
defies these great expectations with his
answer to his book report being a
graffiti illustration of the word
expectations for shadowing his new
spray-painted design on his suit at the
end of the movie as Myles makes his
literal mark on the world but there's a
very interesting detail hidden in this
physics class they watched a video from
the alchemax corporation featuring the
head scientist Olivia now we later
learned that her name is actually Olivia
Octavius
this movie's version of the villain Doc
Ock but this early moment foreshadows
the later revealed
notice how Myles stands directly in
front of her last name hinting that
she's someone important also the number
eight shows up a ton around olivia and
right away here you can see that number
in her character design her glasses
frames are octagons later miles ditches
his homework to hang out with his uncle
Erin voiced by Moe Herschel Utley he
moonlights as the villain the Prowler
and look closely the part in his
apartment and his clothes they all
features some large predator cats
actually I think the painting above the
couch says the word Prowler if you look
closely at those skewed letters now over
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe Donald
Glover plays the live-action version
though of Aaron Davis I don't want those
weapons in his neighborhood I got a
nephew Olivia Glover actually voiced
Miles Morales in the animated series now
mouths visit with his uncle's scored by
Biggie's hypnotised
biggie was famously a Brooklyn rapper so
this music here is another thing that
identifies this spider-man as a uniquely
Brooklyn one and as mouths and Aaron
tagged miles his expectations design on
the wall Myles gets bitten by the
alchemax 42 spider
hilariously swatting it off he gets to
spider-man powers II klutz as his way
through school actually loved how the
school security guard who chases miles
is listening to the spider-man Christmas
album that we saw earlier and this is
actually Chris Pine himself doing the
vocals of the stringer bell's parody you
actually hear a full version of the song
in the end credits and it's miles hangs
on the side of the school building fun
little joke with the hang in there Kitty
motivational poster annalen miles ends
up in his dorm room the comic book that
lands
space is another real spider-man comic
book cover amazing fantasy number 15
miles panics elixirs phone contacts and
if we look closely he Scrolls past the
names of B Bendis sera pucelli those are
shoutouts to the creators of the Miles
Morales character The Ultimate Comics
and miles witnesses Spider Man locked in
battle with Green Goblin he's actually
the monstrous Ultimate Comics version of
the villain in those comics Green Goblin
is the one who kills Peter Parker not
kingpin Prowler also shows up to fight
Spidey and later spider-man villain
tombstone shows up as part of kingpins
henchman team kingpin Wilson Fisk
oversees this Collider test run he's
voiced by Liam Schreiber I like all this
movie stays true to kingpins gargantuan
size from the comics I guess there's
only so much you can do with force
perspective on Vincent D'Onofrio and
Michael Clarke Duncan
now when the collider turns on notice
how the interdimensional particles
take the shape of Bend day Inc that's
the zip this device is tearing the
fabric of these different comic book
universes and causing the ink from the
pages to spill onto each other and on a
screen beside kingpin you see the exact
dimensions that are being linked the one
in the center there universe is II 1610
while the others show II 6 1 6 8 13 9 0
4 1 2 e 1 4 5 1-3 and E 83 11 those are
all the exact Marvel Universe numbers
for respectively Miles Morales Peter
Parker spider Gwynn spider-man noir
penny Parker and Peter porker and with
Goblin holds Peter into the particle
beam Peter enters this trippy weddy
interdimensional space actually all the
spider people are shown getting sucked
into this realm as they're crossing over
to another dimension this could be the
web of life and death beneath in the
comics that's the visual construct
showing the cosmic connection between
all the different parts of the Spiderman
multiverse and after kingpin kills Peter
miles runs off and watches the world
mourn the death of spider-man now these
various shots of Times Square are filled
with easter eggs and animation details
there's the movie billboard for from
dusk till Shawn which is a nod to the
movie Shaun of the Dead from dusk till
Shawn was actually Edgar Wright's tidal
idea for a Shaun of the Dead sequel with
vampires like from dusk till dawn
there's another movie poster for a seth
rogen comedy called hold your horses and
a show called clone college which is a
fictional spin-off of the animated
series Clone High
created by spider-verse
producers Phil Lord and Chris Miller
there's also an ad for a Broadway show
called tie hello a nod to oh hello from
the bridge way show from Nick Kroll and
John Mulaney
John Mulaney of course voices Peter
porker and it looks like an earth 16:10
New York's baseball team is the New York
Red Sox and according to one of the
signs Blake Griffin plays for them shirt
and there's a sign for a restaurant
called planet Inglewood or suspend on
Planet Hollywood there are also signs
for Bendis that's another shout-out to
Brian Bendis and aside for Romita ramen
probably a nod to spider-man artist John
Romita senior now leader shouts of Times
Square you can see Redman group a parody
of the Blue Man Group and kiss --lens
which looks like an alternate version of
the weekend star boy album cover they're
also a bunch of science for like the
golden boys Steph Curry and some
all-female movie called baby shower
which kind of looks like a nod to
bridesmaids and a sign for a snapchat
app called peekaboo which is honestly
such a better name than snapchat now
this old morning sequence leads to an
emotional cameo by an animated version
of Stan Lee who runs a spider-man
collectible shop where miles buys a
costume he says about spider-man I'm
really gonna miss him
basically voicing all of our thoughts
about Stan Lee miles is self-training
failure leads him to Peter's grave where
he meets earth-616 spider-man Peter B
Parker voiced by Jake Johnson he says in
his introductory montage that he's been
at it for 22 years compared to Chris
Pine Peter Parker who said he had been
at it for ten this means that that Peter
Parker was 26 when he died and that this
chubby Peter B Parker has lived the age
of 38
now Peter B's intro also shows them
fighting alternate versions of the
villain Scorpion Doc Ock and the lizard
he also blows all of his money trying to
open a TGI Spidey's restaurant and he
says that he broke his back at one point
which could be a joke about Peter Parker
hurting his back in that scene in
spider-man 2
my back my back by the way that was
apparently a joke about how Tobey
Maguire held out on production for
spider-man 2 because he injured his back
while shooting the movie Seabiscuit and
he was able to convince Sony to pay him
way more money to do spider-man 2 after
that amazing chase scene that we saw in
the post-credits scene of venom Peter
and miles get to know each other and
they head to the alchemax lab in Hudson
Valley
now alchemax is kind of one of these
evil science II corporations it showed
up first in the spider-man 2099 comics
but it was later introduced in a
present-day form in the Ultimate Comics
now here we see even more clues about
this scientist Olivia voiced by Kathryn
Hahn and how she's secretly Doc Ock look
at all the ceiling light fixtures
they're all mucked agonal along with
various octagon shapes throughout the
lab and a true smoking gun you can see a
spare Doc Ock claw laying on the work
table lives notebook also contains the
notes x minus 8 and later the missing
number of the password that Peters
signals to miles is an 8 now we learned
from this sequence that miles has the
power of invisibility which along with
that electric charge thing that we see
later these are all new powers that the
ultimate spider-man gains in loose
comics well detail that I loved as Peter
and Myles escape when Myles checks to
bagel that Peter stole back in the
kitchen hits one of the scientists
firing on him with a little bagel action
word now these two were saved by
spider-gwen when stacey her montage
shows her drumming in the comics Quinn
Stacy plays in the band called Mary
Jane's and she's seen fighting the
lizard who transforms back into a scaly
man and dies and she says I couldn't say
my best friend this is a reference to
how in those comics Gwen Stacy
spider-man faces off against a Peter
Parker who turns into the villain the
lizard and right before she gets sucked
out of her dimension you can actually
see a Doc Ock claw reaching out to try
to grab her so we can think of it this
way by defeating Doc Ock in this reality
spider Gwynn finally finishes that
battle next we learned why kingpin is
experimenting with alternate emissions
to begin with a flashback shows his
ex-wife Vanessa Fisk and his son Richard
Fisk these are both part of the kingpins
back story in the comics we also saw
Vanessa Fisk show up in the daredevil
series the team heads to Queens to the
home about May she's voiced in this
movie by Lily Tomlin she brings them
down into ultimate Peter's high tech
spider cave which also has a ton of
references there's a spider-man
skateboard spider-man action figures a
spider mobile that actually originated
from a run of spider-man comics
70s that was focused on selling toys and
of course there are a ton of Spider Man
suits here the ones I spotted and was
able to recognize there's the iron
spider suit from the Marvel Civil War
comics that has the gold lining that was
meant identified Peter as part of Team
Iron Man to the left of that is the
spider armor inkay to which Peter
actually designed to be bulletproof for
a brief period when he lost his spidey
sense and couldn't dodge bullets and
next to that I think kind of looks like
the Secret Wars suit remember that had
the white spider logo when the Venom
symbiote briefly attached to spider-man
then there's the big time stealth suit
which Peter makes in response to these
spider-slayer program and beside that
it's a suit with the Cape that miles
points out to Peter that looks like the
Cape that Spiderman wore in the Marvel
Comics of wet if series issue 19 that's
when Spiderman became a TV star there's
also what looks like The Secret Wars
stealth suit and it won't point the
background you could definitely see the
white logo of the suit from the recent
spider-man ps4 game ok next Aunt May
introduces the full team including three
other spider people first there's
spider-man noir from Earth 9 0 to 1 for
he comes from a darker crime-ridden
1930s world and he's his guns he kills
people he's voiced by Nicolas Cage then
there's penny Parker from Earth one four
five one two she actually gets adopted
by Uncle Ben and Aunt May and she pilots
this mix by eager robot with the help of
a fighter she's kind of telekinetically
connected to she's voiced by Kimiko
Glenn and then of course there's Peter
porker spider-ham from Earth 83 11 he
was actually a spider bitten by a
radioactive pig which turned him into a
pig with the abilities of the spider
he's always played comedian John Mulaney
now in addition to these new intro
montages notice how the animation style
changes for each new character like noir
has a monochromatic Frank Miller's Sin
City style aesthetic penny / Kerr has a
really bright sailormoon anime style and
Peter Berger is designed in the style of
Warner Brothers Looney Tunes characters
moves a lot like Porky Pig in space fan
and is they examine kingpins crime
operation another Marvel villain shows
up this is a villain hammerhead it's got
a big dumb blockhead he actually doesn't
show up in the movie at all instead
scorpion ends up joining the villain
team later on now when miles runs off
his father runs through his phone
contacts trying to find him and a bunch
of names show up as Easter eggs Dee
Cowen probably Dennis Cowen longtime
comic book artist see McKenna I'm
thinking that's Chris McKenna he's a
screenwriter and friend of
Gordon Miller he worked on the Lego
Batman movie and anime and the wasp and
homecoming and far from home T McFarlane
probably for Todd McFarlane's spider-man
artist and co-creator of Image Comics
and at the end you can see Steve Ditko
listed he along with Stan Lee was one of
these major comics pioneers he
co-created the spider-man character and
a bunch of other characters and passed
away earlier this year that's why that
post-credit moment honored both Stan Lee
and Steve Ditko after kingpins crew
attacks Aunt May's house and kingpin
murders uncle Aaron the other spider
people find miles in his dorm room in
the scene he could see that he has a
chance the rapper poster for the mixtape
coloring book mouths roommate walks in
on them and we never really hear
anything from this guy I'm thinking this
could be a version of gawky Lee from the
Ultimate Comics the character of medley
the spider-man homecoming basically took
everything from that character and he's
reading and imagine that comic that
seems like a nod to the what-if series
now later miles escapes the webbing that
Peter puts him in by accessing his
electric pulse power and he suits up
with his new badass black and red suit
actually a detail really liked here
notice that when Myles takes his big
leap of faith and he swings back up his
wooh cheer up as letters and that
contrasts the earlier moment of his
failed jump remember when his terrified
aah followed him down it as he swings
into action Myles passes a neon sign
reading Perry Joe it's actually a nod to
the guitarist Joe Perry from Aerosmith I
just learned that he composed the
opening music for the 90s Spiderman
animated series as well as the awesome
x-men animated series music and this
brings us to the epic climax of this
movie it's insane it's beautiful there's
random objects floating in a
three-dimensional space is the
dimensions crash on top of each other it
makes for a perfect melee setting for a
group of spider things looking for
surfaces to swing from and among all
this chaos you can actually see some
familiar landmarks surrounding kingpin
there's a red water tower and Brooklyn
Bridge these could be nods to the red
soaked imagery from the opening credits
of the Netflix daredevil show in which
of course Wilson Fisk was the main
antagonist and the end miles defeats
kingpin by using his uncle Aaron's
classic moves the hand on the shoulder
hey this is an example some really good
screenwriting miles is using the wisdom
gained from his uncle to avenge his
uncle and defeat his uncle's killer
full-circle
star wars actually pulled off the same
device right like Darth Vader kills
obi-wan
Kenobi and later Luke uses Obi Wan's
wisdom echoing in this head gain from
their past lessons to deliver the final
blow against Vader and as the various
dimensions crash in on each other the
filmmakers include an interesting shot
of interdimensional webbing flying past
us and notice that they hold on it for a
few seconds longer than you probably
would to me this makes the shot seem
like a possible monstrous Stanley
Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey
specifically that one super colorful
psychedelic long take point of view shot
as we soared through dimensions and then
the final sequence of this movie
bookends the story with the interaction
of Miles Morales he's going through all
the same steps of his counterparts every
time we got to meet them and now he
takes over as a star of this corner with
a spider verse now this movie did have a
post-credits scene that introduced
spider-man 2099 to us actually go into
all the details of that in another video
go check it out but for now question for
you guys how does this spider-man film
rank up against the other spider-man
movies that you've seen like though them
wrong I love Tom Hollands reboot and
Civil War and in homecoming and Sam
Raimi's spider-man 2 is for me one of my
all-time favorite superhero movies
period but I don't know when I see the
look in the design of this into the
spider verse and just the joy of all the
spider people interacting with each
other don't yellow me but this might be
my favorite spider-man movie ever
comment down below with your favorite
cinematic spider-man and follow new rock
stars on Twitter at new rockstars and
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
leave us and subscribe new rock stars
for Spyder everything you know one of
these days you're gonna go look at the
spider-man suit that I'm always wearing
underneath these clothes
that's why you gotta subscribe and you
gotta watch everything oh shoot I think
I got a good oh dang any said no refunds